c'est une vraie guerre il y encore
quelques années ils ont beau vivre au
corps qui assure les les effets les
tracés des conséquences mais d'un
véritable révolution qui affecte
aujourd'hui le commerce commerce de
proximité des commerces indépendants
l'été c'est la révolution numérique il
ya eu des choix politiques passées
peut-être qu'à l'époque c'était
judicieux de favoriser l'implantation de
grandes surfaces où c'était un phénomène
de mode à l'échelle nationale et donc on
pouvait pas y couper
elles sont là et au lieu de lutter
contre il faut qu'on en fasse une force
mais on en n'est pas pour faire la
guerre on pense que d'une façon générale
en fait c'est les grandes surfaces sont
en perte de vitesse
un gamin dans d'autres villes aussi on
évidemment favorable davantage aux
commerces de proximité à développer les
circuits courts
donc pour nous c'est une davantage
créateurs d'emplois et et devis pour la
ville va pas faire une liaison de
navettes gratuites entre le parti
grandes surfaces et le centre-ville
oui vraiment faire une trouvé cette
synergie entre les deux parce que ça
fait partie des structures du territoire
ça peut favoriser l'attractivité en
termes d'offres commerciales donc il
faut juste trouver le le le lien ou
méliand en prend les deux pauses espère
que nous ayons avec et collectif de
commerçants avec les commerçants nous
puissions développer le e-commerce à
l'échelle de la ville
ce qui veut dire que vous pourriez
commande est allé chercher dans la
boutique si vous souhaitez le seul click
and collect sûr et puis surtout je veux
aller jusqu'à système de livraison